Use the line segments below
to create a quadrilateral, so
a four-sided figure,
with vertices
at the following points.
So they give us four
coordinates right over here.
So those have to
be where the sides
of our quadrilateral intersect.
So one is at the point 0, 9.
So our x-coordinate is 0.
So we're at 0.
And then our y-coordinate, or
our vertical coordinate, is 9.
So we need to have a
vertex right over here.
Now, the next one
is at 0, negative 7.
So let me just put
something here.
We can later rearrange it to
see what actually makes sense.
Then we have 8, negative 7.
So 8, negative 7
Is right over here.
It feels like this
might be the right edge.
So I'll put its other point
right at 8, negative 7.
And then finally, 8 comma 0.
Well, 8 comma 0 Is
right over here.
So it looks like I have a point
on every one of the vertices.
So now I just have to
connect to these two,
and I'll have a
four-sided figure.
So let me take this there,
bring this one over.
And let me move this one up,
and then bring this one down.
And there you have it.
I think I've got
my quadrilateral.